l'environnement protecteur c'est aussi
la sensibilisation des adultes de tous
les adultes qui entourent les enfants
alors les parents en premier lieu d'où
aussi l'importance de l'information sur
les risques il faut que les parents
sachent par exemple se les risques liés
à la consommation de cannabis il est
leurs adolescents le font mais aussi
parce qu'ils ont un rôle primordial à
jouer on a encore en France une
initiation qui se fait à certains
produits trop souvent en famille et là
il y a deux produits un peu phares
malheureusement la matière c'est
l'alcool premièrement on a encore 44%
des enfants de 6e qui ont déjà goûté de
l'alcool en sixième c'est pas avec les
copains c'est dans le cercle familial
donc ce sont généralement à l'occasion
de faire de famille parfois sous le
couvert d'éducation goût mais on a
encore des pratiques familiales qui qui
conduisent à une initiation beaucoup
trop précoce en matière d'alcool et on
se situe de très loin par rapport à tous
les autres pays européens en la matière
autre produit ce sont les jeux d'argent
et de hasard là aussi sans penser à mal
souvent initiation se fait des mineurs
se fait en compagnie des parents on va
acheter un jeu de grattage dans un point
de vente Française des jeux on fait des
paris sportifs ensemble en ligne devant
le match du jour mais là encore on sait
que ces initiations trop précoces ont
des impacts ensuite sur les conduites
addictives des jeunes devenus adultes
donc là encore des messages importants à
faire passer sur le rôle de chacun et
sur la nécessaire mobilisation des
adultes on rêve qu'un jour dans la queue
dans un buraliste les adultes ces meufs
lorsque le buraliste vend un paquet de
tabac un mineur et puisque cette
tolérance sociale à la vente aux mineurs
elle aussi baisse